[Music]
in no-meat shame news yes I've seen me
refer you to meet me what that is I was
thinking like girls I thought it was
like the rib I was talking [ __ ] to the
sirloin submitted by bytes mom live in
Bart's brain for a day wow I just saw
ribeye get all sassy like me too I think
he's too violent
no but it takes him a lot to get to that
place this guy though I feel like he at
home I'd go with this guy any day
who do you think would be the best
serial killer out of this guy well sure
for sure Joel he's twisted I don't do
that stuff I don't even think that stuff
that's why you're the minister of
punishment Joe signature would be the
type like he would kill a person bury
the body but leave like a signature
which is like a little muddy I see right
here a little thing a little instrument
for a body he was a little like
instrument with every little guys are
just kind of like a like a signature
thing yeah but he'll be known as a
musical killer hmm
throw off my scent by making them think
I'm Mexican mix of your [ __ ] bottle
horchata
I think the serial killer is Mexican
served and somewhat etches a study found
that men fear the social shame of
ordering vegetarian and vegan dishes
really hell no I guess salads all the
time how much of a [ __ ] do you have to
be to be afraid to order salad yeah
that's the same kind of [ __ ] it isn't
by tampons for his girl yeah like I mean
I order Shirley temple's and my
girlfriend roasts me the whole [ __ ]
day and I don't give a [ __ ] cuz she
still gets the cherry I'm like still
like literally I've never seen a guy buy
a tampon and we look at him away gay you
know we don't ever thinks of that it's
like you're getting late cuz you have a
girlfriend yes
you guys think that maybe cuz there's a
bird no like bang like other guys I mean
I can't speak for all guys but I don't
live in the mind of a [ __ ] so I don't
know yeah like when I order Sally when I
order salad I'm just thinking I'm a [ __ ]
so good later like nothing else is on my
mind I can't even understand like I
don't want this waiter to judge me yeah
I can't even imagine that that's when
guys order salads I feel like it's
responsible that they care about them I
got a salmon skin salad yesterday man
and I got a salad this morning yeah why
would you why would you [ __ ] make up
one food like feminine yeah like that's
your choice you say it's vegetarian yeah
that's not a feminine thing to do I just
like what do threats you're scared to
order like girly drinks cuz it comes in
a nice little dainty glass I love I love
that [ __ ] yo where's the [ __ ]
umbrella do it I get offended where's
the photo boo boo boo is this like a
Middle America type of like machismo
like I only eat me [ __ ] there I mean I
feel like a closeted gay imagine being
so fragile that a [ __ ] plate of salad
makes you feel like you're not a man I
know that's sad so sad I will then I'll
be like [ __ ] I'm not gonna die of heart
disease
these are British men that were
participating in it maybe they have
different social like expectations out
there holy yeah so sciences from the
University of Southampton
they found that men who dislike meat or
they can't eat it because of health
reasons that they find it really
difficult to pick a vegetarian or vegan
dish from a menu because they're scared
of being ridiculed so they've been who
who who's already killed British men I
don't know cuz I can see it like Mexican
men like going like that yeah like
really maybe they don't have good
vegetables out there because like for
example in Asian cuisine there's so much
[ __ ] good veggie choices like
stir-fried
snow peas and [ __ ] green beans and
all kinds of [ __ ] right and then like
also like we have a lot of restaurants
here to have bomb-ass salads like that
all
has meat on no put their time you two
masculinity I see what Jill is saying
like before when I would go over to our
house if like let's say there's cake or
something and I refused to eat it and
everyone would be like all the dudes but
oh let me guess you're on the [ __ ]
diet or something yeah I got so I could
see that they're like because I'm on a
diet I worry about my figure worrying
about your figure worrying about your
figure this is a feminine thing cuz if
you're a man you just get bigger fatter
we're big and fat but like that's like
that's the least of your worries
let me guess okay imagine a bodybuilder
he's Jack is [ __ ] and he's trying to cut
you know guys are wealthy but I just
hate watching guys eat salads because
they don't try to like tear the lettuce
apart it's like they're shoving like
pages yo are you know it's so you look
like horse [ __ ] JISC I'll try to get
it over once I get to the good stuff
I [ __ ] hate wedge salad split apart
and then I feel like they can't clean it
because it's hot that well cut [ __ ]
[ __ ] up for me you only had a wedge
salad once in my life and that salad was
amazing I just don't like the process
when it's done right it's good I mean
it's like almost like having a steak and
you just go like this and then the
lettuce was so cold and crisp and like
fresh and then it was really but we can
get that even after cutting it can I
tell you a secret
oh I just pick it up it yeah like a
pizza yeah see the option for a wedge
salad or Caesar and my heart just always
goes to Caesar I can't yeah but you just
said I love wood
one time I had it I loved it but then
that's what I'm saying every other time
I had an opportunity to get it again I'm
like no but I love Caesar even more the
one thing and in my family that I grew
up that's kind of like tying food with
masculinity was growing up my mom always
told me if I don't finish my food I'm a
[ __ ] and if I'm picky I'm a [ __ ] too
so like when I started like by moving
the mushrooms out oh my
now you're such a little [ __ ] right
there guys are picky with their food I'm
immediately like turned off yeah I'm
like gotta get up I don't like people
like that like they only order [ __ ]
chicken fingers and fries at a [ __ ]
sushi restaurant it would drive me crazy
I would lose my [ __ ] mind not a nice
restaurant and you order like a
rotisserie chicken breast unless you're
like a bodybuilder I'm like why is wrong
with you order a salad that's crazy
cuz I'm like why did you guys travel the
world and like we're in [ __ ] Lutheran
Asia or whatever I'm not saying I don't
know about the place like just [ __ ]
some random place and you can't eat
anything so he has to go through this
local mcdonough is when you try it like
you're like hey try this kimchi and we
go
I bet the very Lisa's try it yes try it
you know and then maybe you'll like it
you know but then I hate the ones that
like no I don't like that oh it smells
so funny
he gets frustrated so much especially
with me to like then you go up like that
too is it in this culture like if you
don't eat everything and if you don't
finish your food yeah it like then
you're considered a [ __ ] too
is that why is that why gets mad enough
maybe I don't know what are you a hotdog
there was like two things that my
grandparents and still doing was every
grain of rice you don't eat
they taught me like every grain of rice
you don't eat is a single maggot you
have to eat when you're dying Wow there
was a pimple on your face or some [ __ ]
no a mega it so like if you don't eat a
bowl of rice that means that you why do
they make it so close to what it
actually looks
I hate maggin and they told me like it's
if it was something I did want to either
like if you're dying on an island and
there was only bitter melon you have to
know how to eat it I was like oh [ __ ]
right and that's how big that [ __ ] ain't
working on me what island is only gonna
have better moment every like I'll die
she did not make it when I finish my
rice Oh Oh cuz she doesn't want you to
be sad you finish your rice you go get
fat but also it shows that like it's
like what peasants did back in the day
because it's like cheap all Chinese and
creepy best friends for each of the
facial food yeah my fiance can't eat all
my rice I never eat the right you know
that's a thing of moms yeah like you're
not supposed to scrape [ __ ] either cuz
it's like what the [ __ ] are you a
peasant no dog I hold the bowl up with
the spoon yeah yeah that for Mexicans at
least is like what the local evening
from the floor uh yeah you're like an
animal that's like I'm trying not to eat
maggots in the afterlife so I just
finish every no we're [ __ ]
yeah we always have leftovers at a
restaurant too even if it's like the
most expensive restaurant she plans to
have leftovers she plans leftovers
alright leave that leave a kimchi we're
leaving this no she doesn't want the
waiter to think that like we barely
could eat here we could just come here
yeah but wouldn't the waiter judge ago
you are wasteful [ __ ] you know
in America it's that way you know I
don't know sister is she the same way
with your sister no not as much because
my sister like has Kahuna's I could
never stand up to my mom what Kahuna's
balls water
come on it I thought it was a disease
she has Kahuna so she gets special
treatment something called Kahuna Big
Kahuna yeah
Hawaiian [ __ ] that's so funny the top
dog on the beach or suffering from
Kahuna's it's like well my sister has
Kahuna Clemons our drawer no cojones
funny I don't know by the actor that
goes to be balls I always thought it was
like concern is no causal
you have balls
maybe it's Italian
[Music]
Oh